I definitely want to know what is it
like working with Tom and Cruz and
they've talked about how they will find
things in the moment they'll reshoot
they will whatever it takes to make this
movie what is it like as an actor where
you might shoot something multiple times
well you know that's what they pay us to
do Tom tell me your name again Jeff
Steve Steve I was close
Steve that's what they pay us to do uh I
I happen to love what I do for a living
so for me it's exciting you know
whenever whatever they want me to do
I'll do short of jumping off a cliff or
doing some insane stunts like Tom Cruise
other than that you got me this I've
seen the film it's incredible what are
you most excited for audiences to see
I'm excited for them to see the film
because it's the biggest action
Blockbuster of all time there's no
question about it
it's also the fastest two hours and 30
minutes of the year right Steve yes I
thought it was gonna drag I'm like wait
a minute that's over already it was
insanely fast brilliant absolutely
brilliant that's Chris mcquarie our
directories GNR editor Eddie Hamilton
brilliant absolutely brilliant while I
have you I know that you have been
working on some really cool things
recently so I'm just going to ask you uh
what can you tease about Rebel Moon
uh I'm very happy about that uh that
won't be out till the end of the year uh
but yeah it's a it's a wonderful sci-fi
drama and uh Sophia boutella is the lead
in it and uh yeah I'm curious who you
play I can't tell you that got it see
Steve right then I'll ask you a
different one uh you recently worked
with Guy Ritchie and Henry Cavill and a
whole bunch of people and it's basically
uh it's against Nazi so I'm always a fan
yeah well anytime we're against Nazis
it's a good thing yeah it's great it's
based on a true story and it's my second
time working with guy and uh he's just
wonderful he's a wonderful filmmaker is
it like a funny guy Richie or is it a
more serious guy Richie World War II so
I mean all guy Richie movies have an
element of guy Richie's humor so it
obviously has an element of that but
it's a much more serious film yeah
you're also doing Knuckles yes sir what
can you do is it a live action or are
you a voice yeah live action so what can
you tease about it well uh that's a
spin-off of Sonic the Hedgehog as you
know Knuckles and uh the voice of
witches uh Mr Idris Elba the great Idris
Elba
um I play uh
Pistol Pete Whipple he's a 27 time
Championship bowler and yeah it was a
lot of fun a lot of fun as I said you
are doing some very cool things recently
thank you thank you Steve